hi there steve kaufman here
um today i want to talk about
arabic grammar and how i am coping with
arabic grammar or not coping or at least
explain my strategy all right now uh if
you look up on the internet which
languages are difficult and stuff arabic
comes up there as difficult
uh
you know if it takes six months to learn
german it's supposed to take two years
to learn
arabic and i can see that and um it's
right up there with chinese as a
difficult language apparently
so how am i dealing with that well
my basic approach to learning hasn't
changed i simply listen and read i have
listened to these many stories
10 20 30 times and you know there's a
total of 60 stories
and i would say that a lot of them now i
basically know all the words i
understand everything there what i hear
when i'm listening
uh is instant meaning to me
that i'm so familiar with hearing these
words these verbs nouns adjectives that
it's meaning to me i'm not concerned
about what i can say
uh my known word counted link is around
1800 and i have said before that it's
only when i reach 3 000 known words at
link that i will start speaking to
people and that's still a month or two
away but that's fine
um now the grammar
i'm beginning beginning to become aware
of certain things in arabic grammar and
in fact i even have
you know a book which i have
flipped through occasionally and every
time i read it it's as if i'm reading it
for the first time because i forget most
of the stuff that's written in there
uh
one of the things in arabic is that
not everything that you say or hear is
actually written for you
so a word
uh
which ends in ah it might actually
you have a tune that's added to it or a
t or something depending on whether it's
and i'm not entirely clear on whether
it's the nominative or the genitive and
i don't worry about it because
all these words that i'm hearing
and often often too in arabic there's a
liaison on to the next
word
i'm not worrying about this stuff i
occasionally look it up it says that
that genitive is this way and the
nominative and the feminine and the
masculine stuff and i never retain any
of this stuff
but it's just that i become increasingly
aware as i'm listening whereas the first
time i might only have heard
you know the uh
what was it
i became more aware of that final little
sound that isn't written for me
and and i'm quite comfortable with that
i'm quite comfortable with just letting
the language come into me and at some
point
i will you know on the you know nth time
when i read through this little not so
thick grammar book some of the stuff
will become even clearer because if i
see there that there's eight types of
verbs as it says in this book eight
types of verbs in arabic i am not going
to go through and
i try to understand how these verbs are
different and then try to remember how
they're different it just isn't going to
work
and
in my experience and it reminds me that
there was actually
a person a gentleman who commented
to judge by the the icon here
who commented uh and said
everybody this is
d sean forsyth commenting on one of my
videos here at youtube said everybody
learns by focusing on a thing and
receiving lots of input of all kinds in
mostly random order and the brain sorts
this stuff out beyond our level of
conscious awareness
and then we begin to sort the thing out
ourselves on the conscious level
so this is it we are we are receiving
all this stuff but teachers he says who
learn this way because they're humans
but then they systematize everything and
they give it to students in a systematic
fashion
that is totally unlike how teachers
themselves learn the thing to begin with
so the ordering and systematizing and
rule forming and all that stuff
can only come after
a ton of stuff has actually been
absorbed and this is such an important
point i totally agree
with uh
sean forsyth and it reminds me of
something else that
on uh on twitter uh
someone that i follow us at twitter or
linkedin i don't know
commented on the fact that
um
if we learn things
uh like if we learn um
it's what's called semantic lists you
know semantic context versus the math
theme like thematic concept if you try
to learn
all the colors
uh all the parts of the body all the
different names of relatives
uh
names of fruits and vegetables as a
batch it's very very difficult on the
other hand if these pop up
in various bits of content that you're
listening to
eventually
red green orange apple banana it starts
to click in so
i think the important point here is that
i believe for a majority of learners
systemizing things like arabic grammar
in fact doesn't make it easier to learn
at some point you can go and review what
you have already experienced
and
reading some of these rules and
explanations and examples is going to
help highlight things that you have
already noticed like i have noticed
these things in arabic i noticed that in
the verbs depending on whether it's uh i
you he she we
that the verb the uh
prefix changes i'm not entirely sure but
i'm getting more and more comfortable
i'm fine i'm starting to recognize it if
it's it's
that's a female that said that that
otherwise it would be yuri duan or
so there are things that i start to
notice but if i had been fed all of that
up front it would have discouraged me so
my way of coping with arabic grammar
which i gather is quite complex is to
not be too fussed about the fact that
it's complex by the time i've had enough
exposure and have become aware of stuff
and the brain has started sorting things
out on its own because again
my total focus is on input i don't
expect to be able to speak to say
anything until the brain has been fed
enough
and i certainly don't want to speak to
anyone if i don't understand what
they're saying so i'm focusing entirely
on and getting this into my brain
and that in this way it doesn't matter
that it's complex it doesn't matter by
the time i have all that input it won't
be so complex whereas if i'm faced with
the complexity of arabic grammar up
front i would find that daunting
intimidating so that is how i am coping
with arabic grammar
and i think probably the same principle
applies to learning other languages so
thank you for listening and if you enjoy
these videos please subscribe
[Music]
you